So I I'd love for you to,
to go back when you first decided to elevate everyone's salary to
70,000, which gained you national fame and accolades,
and you took a pay cut personally in order to make this
$70,000 salary floor possible.
Yeah, well,
I had been indoctrinated and all the things that you're saying that we both been
talking about in terms of kind of the system and how other companies think about
things, the supremacy of shareholders, all those things,
but it was going against what I was actually seeing with my own eyes.
And so in 2011,
I was really inspired by an employee who was telling me she wasn't making
enough. And she had to take a second job at McDonald's to afford,
to be able to work at my company. And I'm like, yeah. And I'm like, you're like,
you're one of our best employees. Like if you can't afford to live your life,
what does that say about me? And so in 2011, at the end of the year,
we set a goal to average, 15% raises in 2012.
And then that we thought would decrease the profit.
We were looking to rebalance the pie and make it more fair because that's what
we thought would happen based on everything that's set out there.
But our profit actually went up. So we decided, well, we'll do it one more time.
Only in 2013. And we did it again. We exceeded the goal, our profit went up,
so that was happening every year.
And we thought this is the way to run a business. And in 2015,
we did a survey across our whole company.
And people were generally pretty pleased with how we were structured,
but I went on a hike with my friend, Valerie, who was in the army for 11 years.
And she's such a hard worker and such an amazing person.
And she was explaining to me how a $200 rent increase was throwing her entire
life upside down. And I was like, that doesn't make any sense.
You're one of the best people I know,
like how is this possible that you're not being compensated fairly?
And then I learned something very inconvenient,
which was a third of my employees were making less than what Valerie was making
at that time.
She was making about 40 K and our lowest employees were like 30 or
35. And it was just,
it was just heartbreaking for me.
And I seen like the Daniel Conaman Angus Deaton study about how like,
you know, wellness increases with income until it doesn't.
And I'd read all these things, but ironically, and I'm not proud of this.
It took almost like emotional purse,
personal experience where this person that I genuinely like love and care about
and respect so much was not being taken care of by our economy
where I realized I was, I had built a company where I can make decisions,
and yet I was just following what everyone else was doing.
What was hurting her rather than doing what I think any five-year-old would know
would be the right thing in that situation. Well.
Channeling your inner five-year-old Dan,
because you then became a national hero in some circles, my circles,
uh, when you said, you know what,
we're gonna make sure that everyone who works for this company gets paid $70,000
minimum, which happens to track with about the income level,
where money no longer affects happiness,
because you would have now have enough to meet your everyday needs.
Yeah. And I would also say that, like, I, I appreciate you saying that.
I think,
I think ideally we would have a world where I don't get so much credit for doing
this and I think I get way too much credit. And it was shocking to me, you know,
somebody that grew up in Idaho and like getting on the local Idaho news would be
like being a celebrity in my world. Like let alone,
like the New York times and all these other places I'm talking to you. And I,
it, it caused me to reflect and be like, why is this happening?
And I don't think it's happening because I'm such a great person.
I think it's just.
Cause everyone else is so.
It's an indictment on the system. I mean, it is, it is funny,
but it's true.
It's an indictment on the system that somebody that just does something very
logical, like says, Hey, all of us built this together. Shouldn't all of us,
at least be able to enough to live like a normal life that that is so radical
and noteworthy, um, is really shocking to me. And I think, uh,
we should be somewhat ashamed as a society that that's where we're at right now.
There are certain organizations where I completely think they
could have done what you've done like a while ago.
So some of these organizations that are now incredibly wealthy and
valuable, and oftentimes the leader ends up hoovering up.
The lion's share of that value in these situations. Uh,
I can relate to a lot of your story Dan, in that. Uh,
but this is one thing I will suggest is that your business,
it was in a situation where if you invested more in your people,
then it spurred more growth, better oppor, better morale,
better retention, uh, more creativity. Um,
I ran an organization that was in a similar boat where if you're a growth
company and you invest in your people, then you end up growing more.
It's like this magical relationship. And, and I'm proud to say that,
uh, no, I, uh,
was following some of your playbook during that time where I would pay people,
uh, more, there was always like a level where you kind of sensed cause you know,
you're the CEO of a small business. Like you kind of get it. It's like,
I know I can get you for this much, but I don't,
I'm going to pay you a little more than that because I think you're going to be
just happier, like better, more productive, less stressed out, more content.
Like I also was always like, whatever. I think I can get them for. Like,
I'm going to like go a little bit above that and it's good.
For us, right? If we're like engaging with them and they're a little happier,
a little less stressed out than we're happier and less stressed out.
That's true. I wired the same way you are, which is like,
I want the people around me to be happy.
You don't want them not to be stressed out about it. $200 rent increase. Like I,
you know, like I think that would just be better for us all. And in my case too,
I did some things where, uh,
and this is one of the joys of being a small business owner where I was like,
you know what? Like, we should all go to the beach. I'm going to rent a house.
It's gotta be a big house to accommodate everybody. And that'd be like,
everyone bus us to the beach or I want to take everyone skiing or whatever the
heck it was. Uh, those were the days. I mean, I I'm still missing them.
Like, uh, my, my now wife and I were dating during this time.
And she also was like, Oh, I miss those days because like this and,
uh, you know, you're positive. You want to look out for people.
I will say I'm sympathetic to folks who run certain types of
operations and other industries where frankly like that relationship might not
apply. Where if like you invest more in your people,
like maybe you're in like a no growth, uh, environment
that then you're like kind of managing now that that's,
I think most businesses are in situations where they would benefit from treating
people better, higher morale, like higher contentment, lower turnover,
like the vast majority of business, I believe fall in this camp. Uh, and I'm,
I'm happy to say that. Uh,
I think that you and I had similar kinds of experiences as the heads of small
companies.
I'll say though, in our industry, if you look at our competitors,
they have done massive numbers of layoffs.
They've increased the fees that they charge to small businesses in opaque ways
that those businesses can't understand or can't see right away.
So they can't be held accountable very quickly.
And then there are some companies that are doing a lot of great innovation,
but those companies are telling their shareholders that they're going to turn
around and flip the switch at some point and start to charge those customers a
lot more or like start to figure out how to control costs in the ways that
you're describing.
And I feel like I did get kind of something wrong in terms of my
expectations over the past six years. And that is, I thought, you know,
with all the hubbub and how, you know,
kind of how much attention we were getting,
if we came out and prove that this could work,
that we would have a lot of people following suit. And we have had, you know,
dozens of companies follow suit and maybe some, some others in big ways,
but like generally the problems gotten worse. And just,
if I can get up on my soap box for two minutes and highlight some of the success
we've had, I mean, we've tripled as a company in the past five and a half years,
we have 10 X, the number of babies being born at the company per year,
like we've had 50 or 60 babies.
Oh, you have that as a measurement. It's like people are feeling reproductive.
10 X. The number of first-time homeowners, uh,
70% of the people at the company have gotten out of debt.
30% say they've gotten completely out of debt,
but 70% have paid down debt and people have between doubled and tripled their
savings for retirement.
And I think there's real implications here for UBI because the raise that they
got is about the same raise that a thousand dollars times two adults in a home
would get. And most of the people that work at gravity there are,
they are two adult homes. So I think there's implications there. So I thought,
you know,
we prove all of that and you would see this general macro economic trend of
people thinking in this direction.
But I think we've actually proven the opposite.
And I think just the fact that the story is still big.
I think we've proven that people aren't going to do it voluntarily more than
anything else, because we've shown it can work. We've shown where like,
you know, we're still, we're still here. Like we're, I'm not poor.
Like I'm out surfing and playing music and you seem very happy and healthy,
yeah. Have a great life. And yet still nobody's doing it.
And so it's really actually emboldened my perspective on what you're
doing because I've realized I'm not the answer. I mean,
maybe I'm the answer in that.
I can be a part of the story and encouraging people and sharing what I've
learned, sharing what I know,
but we need to all come together behind these types of systemic
solutions. And we can't keep glorifying individual. One-offs like me.
Freaking, man, I want to give you a hug.
I would love a yang hug right now. This guy gives the best hugs for everybody.
Wow. That's so kind of you, you do, uh,
because what you just said is so important where there,
there was like a period and I spent, uh, you know,
seven years or so trying to make something positive happen with venture for
America and entrepreneurship. And I thought something similar. I was like,
if I could just show people that helping these small businesses grow is just a
better path than heading to the
billion dollar bank or the, you know, consulting company or whatever the heck.
Then we could really start to fix things and incredibly proud of
everything that venture for America continues to do.
But I started realizing that the black holes gravity field at
this point is way, way too strong and that, uh,
the software of
our economy that so many people have internalized that, you know,
we're all economic inputs and that if you're a company you have to try and like,
get it down to the very last penny,
you can get away with that as soon as you can.
And as soon as you can throw someone over board,
you definitely should throw them over where like all of these things are so
deeply entrenched, uh,
not just in the operations of these companies,
but in our society and people's minds. Um,
then I realized that we actually need to rewrite the rules of the economy, um,
both from the ground up and the top down simultaneously,
but the top down component required control of the government.
And then I was like, well, how do you get of the government?
And then it's like run for president and wind and have the movement or the
revolution it's like, and that most people watching this know, uh,
would have been a highly irrational ambition circa 2018. When, you know,
Andrew Yang was a, an anonymous, um, entrepreneur.
Um, but it it's born of the same kind of arc that you went through Dan,
because you think, okay, if I can demonstrate this works,
then everyone will be like, well, it works. Let's all treat our people better.
Then when you're like, Oh,
people really won't treat their employees better unless they get dragged to it,
kicking and screaming.
And the only way to drag them to a kicking and screaming would be to actually
get ahold of government and change them.
The rules. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.